[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing neville longbottom
corona squirrel voldemort and madame
hooch's broom flying lesson
more specifically we're going to be
addressing a popular fan theory
which suggests that squirrel tried to
kill neville longbottom
as early as the first book let's dive
all the way back to the philosopher's
stone
and the flying lesson taught by madame
hooch all of the students
well almost all of the students were
nervous for their first brim ride
lined up on the field outside of
hogwarts with brums at the ready
however no student was more nervous than
neville longbottom
who was at this stage of his life an
extremely calamitous young fellow
after madame hooch gives an explanation
on how to raise the brim to your hand
she continues on with the lesson however
without giving the command to take off
neville starts flying into the sky but
neville
nervous and jumpy and frightened of
being left from the ground pushed off
hard before the whistle had touched
madame hooch's lips
come back boy she shouted but neville
was rising straight up like a cork shot
out of a bottle
12 feet 20 feet harry saw his scared
white face looked down at the ground
falling away saw him gasp slipped
sideways off the broom
and at this point madam hooch erupts in
a panic
unsure of what action she needs to take
in order to ensure that neville
lands safely she points her wand at
neville and appears to have some sort of
a plan
but curiously she ends up failing
whatever it is that she was trying to do
merely jumping out of the way this
results in neville's crash
wham a thud at a nasty crack and neville
lay
face down on the grass in a heap his
broomstick was still rising higher and
higher
and started to drift lazily toward the
forbidden forest
and out of sight neville ended up
breaking his wrist from the crash
but what we need to remember is that
things could have ended a lot more badly
than they did
what if neville flew 100 feet into the
air no one could survive
that fall was neville close to dying
what happened
as a professor that instructs students
on how to fly brooms
why wasn't madame hooch prepared for
this eventuality
is this a normal occurrence or was
neville's broom
maybe just maybe cursed enter queerness
quirrell
as we know it was in the same school
year that voldemort had possessed queer
on a squirrel
and was acting as a defense against the
dark arts professor
the theory in question suggests that it
was in fact quirrell
who was responsible for neville's
misbehaving broom and that he
tried to kill neville it suggests that
neville's inability to fly broom
wasn't the result of his own calamitous
nature but was in fact caused by curse
in harry's first quidditch match
quirrell does exactly this to harry
and we know this for a fact jinxing
harry's broom causes harry to fly around
erratically and dangerously just like
the way that neville was flying around
for this reason i think that the theory
checks out
i think that yeah it's quite possible
that quirrell jinxed neville's brum
and tried to kill him the only remaining
question here is
why why would cruel target neville could
it be because neville was the other
candidate that could have been
the chosen one i want to hear what you
guys think of all of this
let me know in the comment section down
below if you enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time your wizard houry